[Musique]
en quelques mois jamais le marché
alimentaire n'est les connu autant de
scandales sanitaires successives quatre
nouveaux cas de contamination à la
bactérie escherichia coli liée à la
consommation de pizzas fraîches up ont
été identifiés puis tony kinder lactalis
cemac sont aujourd'hui l'objet de
plusieurs plaintes après que des clients
et été victimes d'intoxication
alimentaire sévère la pédiatre elle nous
a carrément balancé son pronostic vital
a été engagé
si dans les 48 heures sa touche le fois
le cerveau le coeur c'est fini pour lui
parmi eux de nombreux enfants en france
56 cas de bactérie escherichia coli ou
de mort pour les pizzas buitoni 42 cas
de salmonelloses pour les chocolats
kinder si les produits concernés ont été
retirés en urgence des rayons pour les
victimes ce sont de nombreuses vies
brisées on est restés six jours en
réanimation a eu un pronostic vital
engagé elle a été modélisé jusqu'au 8
mars et ensuite à la fed au jour de
néphrologie ces différents scandales
remettent aujourd'hui en question la
qualité des aliments vendus en
supermarché leurs conditions de
fabrication en usine ce soir autour sur
ces scandales alimentaires et sur le
danger des supermarchés dans notre
dossier de l'été et nous recevant m
richard legrand bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes l'avocat des victimes de but
tony et de ferrero tout à fait de toutes
les familles il y avait plusieurs
familles quasiment alors c'est vrai que
le l'histoire de l'alimentation les
scandales y en a on va dire à tous les
cinq ans si on remonte à 96 et la vache
folle
88 les poulets au dioxyde
il ya eu les steaks hachés à la bactérie
e-coli
il ya eu les lazaina
zac de cheval d'ailleurs parenthèse on a
totalement oublié
les steaks et les tartes au chocolat des
magasins ikea elle de la matière et des
matières fécales en août 2017 scandale
des oeufs condamné au fipronil jeu parce
que ces produits et des 117 encore
scandale du lait infantile lactalis oui
évidemment en 2020 les glaces l oxyde
d'éthylène comment est-ce que vous
expliquer qu'aujourd'hui m dans des
sociétés reconnues établi on est des
scandales pareil avec des pois idées
avec des contaminations à des des choses
qui sont va pas se produire mais mortel
oui c'est la loi des séries série on a
des scandales se succèdent
il ya des carences il ya des carences
des négligences forcément au niveau de
la de la fabrication justement de ces
produits
après
il ya aussi des carences au niveau des
contrôles aussi
c'est quoi proprement le lait par le
lait infantile on va pourrait penser que
c'est parfaitement contrôlé c'est pour
nourrissons qu il la chaîne elle la
chaîne de création est totalement
contrôlée il a pas du tout pas plus que
pour une pizza fraîche quoi
il ya des carences encore une fois c'est
mais pourtant il ya des contrôles
sanitaires n'a pas suffisamment les
mains quand on voit par exemple quand on
voit but tony on a vu des images
effrayantes commence à
l'epita c'était absolument dégueulasse
vous voyez ça vous achetez plus jamais
le paysage étonnant donc qu'il ya des
contrôles sanitaires qui sont
obligatoires qui ont ils sont à quel
rythme ces contrôles sanitaires c'est ça
je trouve qu'il faudrait et un suivi là
dedans non déjà il faudrait multiplier
ces contrôles mais il y en a déjà il y
en a pas assez s'il y en avait on ne
serait pas donc c'est aussi la faute aux
contrôles peut-être qu'ils sont pas
suffisants ce n'est pas assez mais tony
c'est officiel alors oui mais alors dans
les familles donné on va en parler mais
il ya eu déjà des alertes ont été
lancées par les employés sa photo passé
c'est bon épouvantable mais avec des
conditions d'hygiène dramatiques donc
fait qu'yves on pouvait douter qu'il
pouvait y avoir un accident mais dans
quel but tony j'ai entendu dire qu'il ya
encore des way sur larcher qui vendent
des lots de pizzas fraîches qui
proviennent de ce scandale toujours ça
c'est possible est franchement il ya un
vrai problème j'ai été alerté par un
client il y a quelques jours justement
de la présence de par la même loi
humaine nouvelle c'est que la gamme
fraîcheur 8 honni
j'ai un distributeur en plein centre de
paris non loin des champs elysées puis
quoi on avait découvert ça quand j'ai
appris ça j'étais surpris et flatté
qu'on vérifie quand même la présence de
ces produits effectivement les produits
étaient en rayon
des investigations ont été faites juste
après pour voir si ce n'était pas le
seul magasin qui était en question
concernant les recettes cette vente de
produits
mode et on a fait à une investigation
sur paris on avait trouvé que plusieurs
plusieurs magasins en vendait encore
parce que bute à une [ __ ] ni à défaut de
communiquer ce qu'ils n'ont pas fait un
retour a quand même pu rappeler les lots
concernés il ya voilà si vous avez tel
lot de tel mais on était numéro c'est
renvoyé les mais pourquoi ça n'a pas été
fait ça c'est assez invraisemblable mais
oui voyez vous quand on est avocat moi
je suis ici et plus jeune
je peux terminer ma phase ouest est
vicié ses oreilles tout ça me saoule et
vous dire c'est que quand on est avocat
on peut mandater un huissier pour aller
constater chez tel ou tel magasin qui a
encore dû fraîcheur ou des machins comme
ça non beaucoup de paramètres qui peut
pas aller contrôler tous les marchés
magasins jean-louis sié dire si on
reprend le nombre de majeurs en revanche
arias à monsieur mais si on le nombre de
magasins bernard cherchons notre sens ce
distributeur qui en cause dans ses
avants de ses produits il y en a 400
dans toute la france c'est énorme c'est
énorme maintenant on ne sait pas s'il ya
d'autres magasins qui en vendent encore
nous on s'est basés déjà sur cette
enseigne maintenant et vous inscrire
c'est très grave peut-être est-ce que ça
mais oui parce que ça vienne pas
aujourd'hui il ya encore des familles
qui risquent leur peau bien sûr oui en
se disant tiens peut-être qu'elles sont
revenus peut-être qu'ils ont corrigé
parce qu'on fait confiance à une grande
marque un nom et il ya encore entre
guillemets des produits de merde qui
sont plus chers parce que ça revient
moins cher de faire sa propre idée pour
le savoir et j'incite les gens faites
votre pizza chez vous si belle si ça
revient moins cher ça revient moins cher
c'est comme le steak haché 2
c'est bien
mais c'est quand même inquiétant c'est
pour la population aujourd'hui alors je
pense qu'il ne faut pas céder à la
panique je pense qu'ils se trouvent tous
les produits ne sont pas contaminés
la
confiance s'est aussi arrachée mais
voilà c'est ça la chose c'est qu'on a
des produits dont il ya plusieurs gammes
de produits qu'elle soit même marque les
produits se ressemblent je veux dire
qu'on a tout déposer son tour avec des
boîtes vertes mais c'est très difficile
pour un consommateur déjà de reconnaître
des différentes gammes de produits chers
de reconnaître le produit mis en
question et qui est censé être retirés
du marché depuis la mi mars ça fait
presque trois mois déjà c'est scandaleux
et et puis voilà si on trouve un produit
en rayons forcément on a confiance en ce
produit des familles vont à se poser la
question
voilà c'est le produit on va regarder
l'extrait d'un arrêt de bus données qui
raconte ce qui se passe dans l'usiné
quand on voit des champignons au mur
déjà on voit que ça va pas quand la
peinture s'écaille sur les barres en
métal ça va pas c'était bien des bouts
de nourriture qui restait à certains
endroits pendant plusieurs jours
plusieurs semaines par exemple dans des
bacs de rattrapage de sauce vous pouvez
retrouver cette des fois certains des
mégots de cigarettes nauru la farine est
envoyé sur les tapis pour pâques lac la
pâte colle et bah y avait des vers de
farine qui pouvaient tomber
régulièrement et la plupart des gens ne
se lavaient pas les mains ça m'étonne
que ça il n'y a pas eu d'accident avant
alors cette usine était gerber depuis
tant d'années aujourd'hui les inc vous
avez donc vous trouvez des familles
victimes de ces fameuses pizzas et des
produits kinder c'est quoi les séquelles
qu'on retrouve généralement alors on va
voir un témoignage terrible mais
globalement on va parler du pire à
savoir la mort quels sont les symptômes
et les séquelles alors déjà cédé
problèmes gastriques au déjà au départ
après sur par exemple sur la sphère sur
les personnes qui ont été contaminées
par les pizzas avec des sachets on a des
personnes qui peuvent se retrouver en
insuffisance rénale avec des séquelles à
vie
voilà avec des reins qui sont totalement
détériorée et qui malheureusement a
suivi médical avis donc c'est
extrêmement grave on parle d'enfants
sont des enfants qui n'ont pas été
préparés par ce genre de contamination
d'intoxication
elles sont
c'est très dur psychologiquement aussi
pour ses enfants et pour les familles
les parents et les familles combien de
familles ont été contaminées aujourd'hui
alors sur la ferme lui tony on à 56 cas
des sachets donc des formes graves qui
ont été répertoriés eu malheureusement
de décès sur les phobies tony
malheureusement maintenant avec ce qu'on
a on a découvert récemment avec la vente
encore de ses produits ainsi ce dingue
depuis de nombreux mois
on ne sait pas c'est pas on va regarder
le témoignage de d'amélie est la maman
d'une petite fille de 9 ans et après je
vous demanderais ce qu'on peut faire
contre cette fameuse marque qu'est ce
qu'on peut espérer et attendre des
balles à consommer une pizza enfin deux
mais mal à manger de la pizza au fromage
de l'épisode bolognaise le mercredi 16
février le mardi d'après elle a dessiné
la balance elle est malade comme une
pièce trop elle avait des diarrhées
avaient très très mal au ventre elle
avait des nausées mais elle vomissait
pas donc j'ai été chez le médecin
généraliste j'ai consulté le jeudi puis
m'a dit qu'elle avait certainement une
gastro entérite certainement une grosse
gastro comme un rotavirus elle m'a
demandé de faire un prélèvement de
celles que j'ai fait dans la journée
c'était pas comme une baisse trop
j'avais l'impression de chanter qu'elle
n'était pas bien elle se mettait partir
donc je suis parti j'ai consulté aux
urgences pédiatriques à saint-etienne et
ils m'ont tout de suite pris en charge
et ont fait des bilans et là tout de
suite été muté en réanimation donc au
départ à saint-etienne le samedi et le
lundi elle est passée au bloc pour lui
imposer un sheldon à cathéter
d'hémodialyse est là et hémodialyse et
on est restés six jours en réanimation a
eu un pronostic vital engagé elle a été
modélisé jusqu'au 8 mars et ensuite elle
a fait douze jours de de néphrologie
alors cessez votre que c'est votre
cliente
comment évoluer la petite aujourd'hui
alors la récupération est difficile et
longue on a là un état de santé qui
était instable
il est toujours suivi
malheureusement sera surveillé toute sa
vie ou alors elle a été très très très
affectés psychologiquement
c'est mon pare d'une enfant c'est
forcément un traumatisme qui va rester
moi je souhaite rendre hommage à toutes
ces familles à toute infamie
concrètement j'ai discuté un peu moins
chaud qu'à en france si on n'est pas en
l'amérique ça en amérique je vous dis à
600 millions de dollars devrait s'élever
en france on sait très bien que y aura
peu ou pas de coupable et que les
indemnités vont être levée si cela ne
change rien je trouve déjà envoyé des
beaux ils ont envoyé des mails au monde
est d'accord non il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'espoir de faire condamner but tony et
encore moins d'espoir de récupérer même
si ça changera pas forcément l'état de
santé mais c'est un peu d'argent dans
cette histoire c'est très bien que la
demande va être 10 15000 euros grand
maximum non non il y a déjà six il y
avait aucun espoir nous serions pas là
que vous étudiez mais je dis que j'ai
bien confiance par rapport à d'autres
pays comme les usa c'est sans commune
mesure j'aurai le droit n'est pas le
même voilà c'est tout à fait maintenant
déjà pour l'instant nous attendons aussi
que nous puissions accéder aussi à
certaines informations nous n'avons pas
encore accès au dossier d'instruction
ont déjà nous souhaiterions avoir plus
d'éléments avoir plus de lumière
concernant cette affaire avec toutes les
enquêtes qui ont été effectuées
maintenant
nous avocats on ne travaille pas seul on
travaille aussi avec des médecins
experts dont cabinet travail qu'un
cabinet d expertise médicale nous sommes
une équipe semi une équipe et nous
allons évaluer en fait tous les
préjudices que les familles ont subi les
préjudices peuvent être très élevées et
voilà maintenant il va pas forcément car
les nuits c'est déjà dans le cadre de
voler ou benallel volet civil dans le
cas de servier où ils ont indemnisé je
crois 500 personnes il a eu une amende
de 200 millions sur mensah par personne
c'est trente mille euros il paraît qu'en
france c'est le maximum que l'on puisse
espérer déjà le volet pénal volet civil
au volet pénal déjà il faut que les
responsables soient traduits en justice
et que soient condamnés si leur
responsabilité est bien
engagée et il ya le volet civil avec des
indemnisations pour les victimes alors
on espère que d'abord l'évolution de la
santé d'aider des enfants touchés balle
est dans le bon sens déjà oui et il ya
cinq conseils qu'on voulait vous vous
donnez bien cuire les aliments quand
vous achetez des pizzas et autres la
lecture vraiment cuir et vise évidemment
ce run et des aliments crus ça c'est
potentiellement à risque on ne pas se
mentir se laver les mains avant tout à
l'église mais c'est assez allait
reconduire sa mémoire est fait il faut
le faire bien conserver les aliments au
frais ne pas rompre la chaîne du froid
on en parle souvent ça ça a des
conséquences parfois dramatiques en
termes de bactéries et puis évidemment
soigner son frigo salaires bête faut
penser à nettoyer son frigidaire c'est
là régulièrement au moins tous les mois
au moins tout le remercie bien d'en
manquer de nous préciser pour c'est tous
les mois